We have to kick it off
with a crop of fresh golden globe nominations
and yes, you may notice were in mourning.
This is us under here
(laughing)
and that's because "Bridgerton" was totally snubbed.
(shouting)
Our beloved "Bridgerton"
Why would they do that to them?
I don't know.
(mimics sobbing)
I mean with the highest breaking records
on Netflix, the business alone
It is the biggest show in like the longest time.
I think its still the number one show streamed on Netflix.
It looked like it was going to get all these nominations,
nothing!
Not a one.
So well just have to wait till the Emmy's
when those nominations are out
and we'll keep our little veil.
You know what is fantastic about the Golden Globes?
What?
Three female directors this year
(audience clapping)
First time ever!
Extra ordinary!
Absolutely!
Wonderful!
Regina King, Chloe Zhao and Emerald Fennell all got nods.
I mean, that's like just a beautiful thing
Well, you think about what that looks like.
We've never had more women than men--
Yes.
Nominated for best,
it used to be a big deal when we'd have one
The pendulum swungeth the other way,
Chadwick Boseman got a nomination.
So good at "Ma Rainey's Black Bottom".
Yeah I thought
that was an incredibly soulful respectful, beautiful thing.
I'm happy for the "Crown" obviously.
We had Emma and Josh here
on the show who played Charles and Diana.
They were extraordinary.
I missed "PEN 15" and "I May Destroy You".
I would have loved to have seen those shows get recognized
and maybe we can wait for the Emmy's for that.
Well you know I love award seasons
and the Golden Globe is really the kickoff
for like the movie awards seasons.
"Cause it sort of says, these are the Oscar people
that could be nominated for an Oscar coming up.
And the movies like "Trial of Chicago Seven" got a lot
of nominations.
"Mank" led the nominations
this is a black and white film by David Fincher.
I love "Promising Young Woman" and Glenn Close nominated
for Hillbilly Elegy for playing "Most Of My Relatives".
(both laughing)
If you haven't seen that movie
shes so good in that too.
So the other thing is so interesting now
about the Golden Globes
is a lot of time when these movies are nominated
people are like, what is that? I've never heard.
But because of the pandemic
a lot of these movies are streamable right now.
Absolutely.
The ones I mentioned
a lot of them are on Netflix or Amazon prime.
So Google and find out and you can watch them right at home.
Well we have someone who can come and join us
and give us her opinion of which I highly respect.
She is a very, very funny lady--
One of my favorites.
A comedian, an actress,
a New York times bestselling author over and over again.
Another great form in our medium now is Podcasts
and she has an awesome one.
Its called "Go Ask Ali".
It is out now.
I believe its season two.
Please welcome Ali Wentworth.
Ali!
Oh look how good you look.
(clapping)
I wish I could wear a veil too
"cause I'm very upset, but I only could find my wedding veil
which sends a different message.
(laughing)
Or does it?
Maybe when
your fabulous husband George Stephanopoulos comes home
you could, hello, have that kind of an evening.
Nothing sexier than me
with the big veil on my head, but yes.
Well, I'm so interested to hear like your opinion,
did you enjoy the nominations,
did you feel like some was missing out,
what are you celebrating,
what is Ali Wentworth's thoughts?
I thought it was an interesting Golden Globes year.
I was (phone beeps) very upset about "Bridgerton"
but "A Promising Young Woman"
is a fantastic movie.
So I was thrilled and I hope Carey Mulligan wins
because I donut know if you guys saw that piece
about somebody in Variety said, oh, you know
it would have been better if they had someone hotter
like Margot Robbie, which I thought was so enraging.
To say that Carrie Mulligan wasn't hot enough
was extremely offensive.
So I'm hoping shes gonna win.
And she called out that reviewer too
and then Variety redacted it,
they apologized for it.
I'm shocked,
that is in poor taste.
I also know shes married to Mumford and sons.
I think they're like the coolest couple and they have kids
and they're just amazing.
And shes amazing.
I'm obsessed with her.
And she burst on to scene, the scene in "An Education,"
she has been an absolute award-nominated, recognized
highly acclaimed actress.
And this is her moment, which is so exciting.
She could win.
(upbeat music)